es ist servus kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
spielen heute ein paar virtuelle weil
ich immer wieder gefragt werde ob ich
nicht mal ein paar mehr videos auf die
mutter machen können das machen wir
heute es ist gerade von effekt 20 44
nachts in der nacht von sonntag auf
montag ich muss morgen macht aufstehen
zu arbeiten sie das nur am rande wird
sie rein und gucken mal was wir zu solch
später stunde noch im pvp reisen können
ihr seht das video tagsüber das heißt da
kann man doch gar nicht mehr
nachvollziehen glaube ich okay ich
sollte mich nicht so komplett verein
letzte chance du nicht nur mal das
falten kann das gebäude wo er für teile
sagt zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack ward jung ich muss mir einfach
nur den schadens krank drücken ist er
down oder nämlich ganz viel macht er
nicht nur mit der schlecht weg sagt zack
zack zack zeigt sehr schön
ok erste runde gewonnen gespielt und
alles ohne löschen wir müssen ja nicht
eigentlich hatten wir die warteschlange
uns direkt nächsten dauert so hier jetzt
hat niemand weiß wer wir sind und das
war knapp
das war den fall die hat nicht
funktioniert
die ein bisschen besser funktioniert
würde ich sagen und jetzt jetzt jetzt
feiere und in der tat sehr schön
wunderbar zweite runde gespielt zwei
traumtoren und die dritte
ich glaube es einfach mal ganz kurz ein
paar wände montes one wetter ist einfach
zu haben ohne jetzt ein youtuber sich
gegen zu über zu haben
marvin ist dass ich meine da bin ich
auch weniger aufgeregt weil ich bin auch
schon aufgeregt wenn ich weiß ja hören
jetzt gegen den verlierer denken alle
ich bin so so schlecht weil gegen ben zu
verlieren hat schon richtig bitte es
feiern etwa rüberkommt
verarscht und jetzt leute vor ort alter
gepackt die kombos und kombos und ich
hole ihn noch alter shinji sehr schön
wunderbar schreibt bewegen von mal eure
meinung dazu in die kommentare findet es
cool einfach so ganz gechillt ein paar
runden pvp sie kommentiert so mal
einfach mal ein bisschen zu trainieren
weil leute mir auch mal schreiben ich
heute besser pvp mit hatten er scheinbar
auch und natürlich wie man dieses feuer
löschen kann
ich bin darauf zugelaufen im vertrauen
dass man's löschen kann aber man kann es
aber nicht löschen seht ihr das die idee
ist so was von dauern ja wohl schon
sagen fall eines ausfalls landes an
das war's wir haben schon war ja auch
ein hacker so liegen lang lang oder wie
heißt er im chat geschrieben
larini an ja auf jeden fall feedback in
die kommentare
das würd mich interessieren und jetzt
aber wieder ein schadens frankreich und
einige pfeile
weil ich immer noch da gar nicht
schlecht machst du doch gar nicht stellt
mein freund aber jetzt bist du drin
steckt in der lage der kommt da ganz
schlecht aus
schaden ist rang 3 der ist weg der ist
doch gleich weg ja ich habe auch schon
eine heilung geben sehr schön
okay wer gewinnt die roten ihren lauf
verband jaaa wird man schauen dass wir
sieben acht minuten hier zusammen
bekommen wenngleich das ja ganz morgen
ganz machen
ich glaube dass ganz morgen nicht nur
halb denn hier und jetzt eben raus da
hinten rauskommt da hinten raus oder ja
wir möchten ein reifen war aber okay das
wird nicht funktionieren ja wie er die
hits der auspackt ist ziemlich motto go
but i halt mal kurz die heilung mit
drückt ihm den schaden reihen haben
jetzt und weil so mittelprächtig
getroffen und es gibt noch eine schwere
kombi habe ich in der aushebeln
nein nein nein ich bin nicht gerade noch
retten
noch bevor ein jetzt mehr durch es wird
knapp es wird knapp
wir haben ihn geholt damit gut in den
lava getrübt aber es hat doch gereicht
aber okay dann weil er jetzt hier
nächste runde 6 gehören ein paar
niederlagen dazu würde ich sagen respekt
zolle ich habe immer das timing für die
feste nicht so ausgeführt nicht sogar
war er gibt mir wieder gut ist für mich
wie ging das denn alte wie einfach mal
direkt straight weggeholt dort sitzt
ausfall ihr jetzt machen schlecker einer
linkskurve nach links da ist so
schlenker nach links weg in rain zack
zack zack zack zack zack intense pvp er
trifft mich gar nicht mehr alter sehr
schön wunderbar die maps laden so
komisch kann man hier so entkam
beschreibt direktor star selten gelesen
und first ist ein bisschen locker
doppelt geführt wir nicht jeden tag sagt
zack zack zack zack zack zack intensiv
alter läuft beck fühlt sich irgendwie
nicht so krass da wird man seine stats
hier einfach mal ganz fanny society
heister 21 firma kd ich glaube nicht so
schlecht passt würdig sein
so jetzt hab ich gehört willst du mein
schwert fressen
zack und zwar in erster und wunderbar
also erst 21 50h meines stacks wie die
aussehen
jetzt exklusiv in der aufnahme wie
sieht's aus 20.12.10 20
das okay der firma besseres netz als ich
die gaffer magath geholt würde ich sagen
2,0 ist nicht so geil eigentlich warum
was wann wo wie box ist einfach auf der
leiter key einer geht noch einer geht
noch leute kommt jetzt der letzte gerade
eben bin ich auf dieser map geraden dios
gescheitert weil ich mich selbst in
brand gesetzt habe ok wollen jetzt macht
den dreher nach rechts entlarve reihen
ich konnte ihm schwerfällt canalys
das ist lies browser muss das sein und
jetzt habe ich ihn gerade wenig gehütet
wird den hätten können okay wir ein
bisschen die anleihen setzen so wie ja
wie einfach so wenig noch gekriegt von
der anna seghers habe der angriff volle
sein gesicht getroffen so jetzt kriegt
ein mit komm jetzt gehst du noch mal
nach rechts genau jetzt gibt's mal mit
sehr schön
jetzt schaltet die noch nicht genug ist
nicht immer die anderen
take that so kriegt weil ihr eine auf
einer rein geht erheblich schon gesehen
dass wir mitgemacht hast mein lieber ok
jetzt hat christa den ball dafür hat er
trainiert
nein nein könnte dann aber nicht
entschärfen aber das habe ich meine hier
maurer
die partie musste auf die drei ja alles
gut ich hab doch schon längst meinl aber
wieder eingefangen aber jetzt habe ich
bin überrascht habe ich gefühlt
jetzt will ich lieber blazon geht
daneben jetzt wo ich mir kommt sagt aber
auch man lieber face machen hat mich
fasziniert er bringt seine eigene lava
und er ist weg wunderbar und damit
ändert sich die heutige aufnahme ist
auch so ein bisschen ali muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen jetzt zehn vor vier nachts
wüsste ich nicht was ich sonst noch so
aufnehmen sollte ich hoffe ich trotzdem
gefallen schreibt gerne mal rein ob so
was cool findet jetzt das ausnahme in
ordnung war sonst nicht mehr oder
whatever einfach so renten auch von tina
uhlmann wesentlichsten wieder hat ein
macht's gut